Competition breeds rivalry sometimes, it's between organizations. Their
legacies evolving with every exchange.
(Casting)
Sometimes it's two competitors at the peak of their powers trading blows.
But sometimes a rivalry is built from something else.
A difference in mindset.
A casual born from a lack of respect.
When Huk and Idra in the early 2010s, it was the freshed face new hope,
against the grizzled, foul-mouthed, brood war veteran.
And it was always worth watching.
(Casting)
Hey, but before we get into it, if you want this sweet kappa shirt from our "What is" series,
or plenty of other theScore esports branded shirts just like it, you can check out theScore esports merch
department.
Which you can find a link to in the comments below.
"Ladies and gentlement let's introduce our next player, known as the Grakken.
From Team Evil Geniuses, Idra."
Greg "Idra" Fields had long been a foreigner in a game dominated by Koreans.
He even moved to the country and joined Korean teams like
East row and CJ entus. By the time Starcraft II rolled around Idra was the
foremost foreigner in Brood War. But Idra became known for something else too
being unafraid to speak his mind, shit talking on ladder and generally pushing
the limits of sportsmanship.
(Stream)
"Alright, what do you think about cruncher and how do you think this match is gonna go."
"I'm playing really bad but it's more than enough to beat him."
"Alright guys, shake hands if you're going to."
(Casting)
As competition in the west mostly shifted towards Starcraft II, a new breed of foreign hopes
arose and one among them, Chris "Huk" Loranger showed promise.
"This week you are actually in the finals so how do you feel about that?"
"I feel great I mean this is my second LAN of all time so the experience is
definitely adding up, ESL was a real challenge for me just
because it was my first LAN hopefully I continue to do well."
He boasted a strong win-loss record during the games beta period which earned him tournament
invites and a chance to play for Team Millenium."
"I do want to continue to emphasize that fact about Huk the fact that he's just laid back and he's very
embracing of all the situations he's in he doesn't even think of himself as like
the best player in the world he's always asking players for advice and when he
loses games and we've even seen Idra lose games and Idra tends to say oh
that's a terrible strategy you'll never get far doing that. But Huk says god I
can't believe you beat me that badly I gotta figure out how to not make that
happen. And he literally says it like that I've seen him do it in private
practice games with other players." His style was aggressive and unpredictable
switching between standard builds and more unpredictable strategies like the
mothership rush.
(Casting)
But while he was hyped during the beta Huk fell short at his first post release
LAN in Cologne, exiting the tournament in the group stage.
He bounced back quickly taking first place at MLG Raleigh 2010.
(Casting)
The grizzled veteran and the rising star. Idra and Huk were on a collision
course. The two faced off at MLG DC 2010.
(Casting)
Idra sent Huk, who had recently joined Team Liquid, to the losers bracket.
With a 2-0. There against SeleCT, Huk tried out one of the tricks he was becoming known for,
the mothership rush.
But it didn't work out. And Idra took the whole tournament for Evil Geniuses.
"Uh so Huk, re*ard or poster boy for Starcraft II esports."
"Re*ard but since the community's re*arded he's the poster boy."
"Huk made the... He brought in the audience, they laughed it was great, but he threw the game away."
Even though the mothership failed and Idra had won the tournament.
The move brought attention to Huk, and earned him fans in the nascent StarCraft II scene.
Huk lost to Idra again at EG Masters Cup Series 3
With Idra displaying some serious BM as he attacked with his drones, and started building a hatchery
in Huk's main base.
(Casting)
Idra lived in Korea at the time, and travelled to attend foreign events.
While Huk was based in North America.
But Huk made the move to Korea.
Beginning a series of encounters between the two players on ladder,
and further pushing the rivalry.
(Casting)
Huk continued to use unconventional strategies, like cannon rush cheese against
Idra on ladder.
Idra for his part, made it clear he had a distaste for Protoss players.
"Nah he's a piece of trash who wouldn't play any games if he didn't play Protoss."
And their next LAN meeting, MLG Dallas 2011 featured one of the most infamous moments in their rivalry
Facing off in the group stage Idra took game 1 against Huk and it
looked like he would have game 2 as well, he built up a considerable lead and
was just one good engagement away from a win but Idra's late game army had one
major weakness, it wasn't terribly effective against air units like void
rays which Idra suddenly found himself facing down.
(Casting)
The unit's might not have been real, but Huk's victory was.
And Huk wanted Idra to know it.
So he told him the next game.
And got a predictable response.
(Casting)
While Huk won the battle taking that series, Idra won the war.
After the group stage they faced off again, with Idra winning 4-2.
And after the event, he couldn't pass up the chance to talk more shit about Huk.
"So Huk can't win in a real game huh?"
"Pretty much, he wouldn't win at all if he didn't play Protoss, he's actually kinda re*arded."
"Stand by your guns on that one."
"How good did it feel to knock him off after the games yesterday."
"Really really really good."
"I mean Idra can say what he wants, he likes to talk and lie a lot.
I remember in a previous interview he said he beats me all the time when realistically the last 40 games we've
played he's won maybe five. Just sometimes a cocky f*ck and all this other sh*t so uh, you know
I tried being nice to Idra, Idra wants to continue doing whatever he's doing, it's fine with me I don't care."
And while Huk did eventually get the better of Idra,
Wins at Home Story Cup 3, and the North American Blizzard Invitational, put Huk on the board.
The latter victory denying his opponent a spot at Blizzcon.
(Casting)
And by August, the rivalry took an even stranger turn.
Huk left Team Liquid to join Evil Geniuses,
turning him and Idra from rivals to teammates.
"They played it up in the promotional stuff about you vs Huk and this big rivalry thing.
How much was it like a rivarly of dislike before for you and Huk when he was in other teams."
"We never disliked each other personally we always got along pretty well, we have really similar senses of
humour actually."
"We're pretty good friends even before he joined EG. Ah but I just didn't respect his play very much,
and kinda said so, but he's improved a lot, obviously he's been practicing in Korea for a long time.
so there's no friction at all there anymore."
Unable to weaponize your fanbases the same way they used to, that was pretty much the end of Huk and Idra's
rivalry.
Idra continued to talk sh*t of course.
He just directed it at other players after he joined EG.
And after eventually quitting StarCraft II in mid 2013,
Idra had a very brief stint in Heroes of the Storm. Representing EG in the games very first Blizzcon
appearance.
"Honestly a lot calmer playing Heroes of the Storm.
The biggest thing is it's a team game, and it's purely a team game.
It's the opposite end of the spectrum from Brood War, all that matters is how well you work with your team.
And the strategy thinking portion of the game.
And if you get pissed off and start raging then that starts affecting your teammates.
Recently Idra revealed he hasn't owned a computer in some time. And these days he's mostly focused on
fitness.
"No I haven't owned a functioning desktop in like two years now.
I was just a really competitive person and StarCraft happened to be the competition that stuck.
And now... I don't know I was kind of an angry competitor so I don't know how healthy that is.
So I don't compete anymore, I think weightlifting kind of filled that role for me.
But no StarCraft was just a way to beat people."
Huk meanwhile has successfully transitioned into Overwatch.
Where he started as a caster, and has since become the president of gaming for the Kraft group.
Which owns the Boston Uprising.
One player has left esports behind,
and the other is helping build a new pro scene.
But for just under two years, while the western StarCraft II fanbase was looking for
heroes and villains,
Idra and Huk gave them exactly what they needed.
One a foul mouthed confident veteran,
"You're kind of notorious for being a little bit bad mannered, and me knowing you personally I would say
say that might be based in some truth."
"What were your thoughts on that game."
"I just played really sh*tty."
"Short and sweet."
The other a fresh faced new hope,
who knew how to play the crowd.
(Casting)
"Just thank you, I think I have the best fans in the world, and I love you guys and I'm glad you enjoyed my games."
And despite their rivalry being short lived,
the intensity of the two players and the passion of their fans,
made their conflict one to remember.
(Casting)
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.